hello everybody my name is markiplier
and dr. markiplier to you anyway I'm
back here so I need to shut up shop
nurse don't you see I'm busy ok you guys
have told me that I've been making a
little bit of an error you see that
green needle over there got my hand that
green needle actually slows the heart so
after I make my incisions on the rib
Buehler area I can then stop the
bleeding so I can cut willy-nilly
basically to what they're trying to say
so nurse please ready the sponges to
soak up all the blood I will stop it
chemically anyway we're actually gonna
try to do this because I want to see the
rest of the game that there is to offer
so I don't need to worry about cutting
too much outside of the ribs I just need
to be able to get these ribs off quickly
and then I'll stop the bleeding
afterwards man those are some tough ribs
though nurse have you got patients on
calcium no doctor that doesn't make any
sense
Shawn nurse I know what's best right
everybody right
I fight if I could stop cutting into the
flesh that would be just fantastic
ok are the ribs free and others what was
that sound what was that ripping and
tearing sound is there an alien about to
burst out of him Oh his blood is about
to burst out of them if I don't get this
oh no you don't oh no you don't I have I
had it damn it get over here I'm not
gonna lose you I can't lose another one
not another needle bleeding ok here we
go got it alright jab it directly into
the face area there we go he's not
bleeding anymore ha ha how boy sick drop
that right there for future use grab
this
shucks it over here by putting it on
okay it's fine in the last game if you
left a power tool on and just nurse give
me a hand with this I can't seem to get
enough leverage yeah come on good good
thank you
hey you see Bob what do you cooperate
with me this sort of stuff doesn't need
to happen you know you could have kept
this for like days longer so uh yeah put
that in the tray there let's get the
other one my watch
no you're not taking this one you're not
taking it Bob all right you just calmly
listen to the tick ticking of my watch
well hey delicately with one pinky
finger raised that's out of date aah get
off of my needle of good happy juice I
need the super juice all over there okay
so anyway now we just need to dig out
the rest of these organs come here
I still don't know what that is but
probably not too important okay so now I
need to cut oh damn it this is out of my
reach it's out of my reach I can't get
it okay range over there I'll have to
use something else like the drill oh
that sounds like a well not a good idea
but it's an idea
okay now whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa where you going drill where you
going drill come here
hahahaha your stupid game mechanics the
drill is not the correct tool to get out
all my goodness
gotta get the heart just gotta separate
the arteriole ha's and ah I was doing so
good and then he died this guy saved me
forever if I can't get this come on what
the hell happened there okay all right
just don't panic
why I think's beeping Emmy something's
beeping at me rather loud actually
that's that was fine exactly where it
was why did I go through the trouble of
moving it okay so anyway what I'm gonna
do now is I'm gonna try the hammer this
time I'm gonna oh god you stupid watch
it's just gonna put that in a general
grip grabby position so that I can
easily really easily you're come here
[Music]
I'm gonna kill someone I'm gonna kill
someone nurse would you mind assisting
me here in this operating room okay I
finally have the hammer and a hammer
like fashion so we smash I said we smash
smash and then smash smash alright we're
doing good we're doing good no blood
totally got it smash just start knocking
things out of there all right hey it
actually decided to cooperate now the
drill was obviously a poor choice so I'm
not gonna ever let my inner thoughts and
oh my god what is happening in that
chest cavity there's something in there
that shouldn't be here this shouldn't be
here this doesn't look right not right
at all what is that beeping what is that
incessant beeping disturbing my peace of
mind as I'm trying to hear we go come
here come here come here if I don't beat
this there is eventually going to be
more stuff here come on damn it I was
able to do this like easily back in the
original I don't know what they change
to make this so much harder but I just
gotta I just gotta take one of these
very delicate cutting tools very
delicate cutting tools ah just like that
and I need to slow
ice the stomach lining esophageal tube
maybe is what you might call it okay
it's bleeding it's not cut though get
out of there
come on cut cut cut cut cut cut damn it
cut delicate tool my ass
more like wimpy baby tool oh I think I
got the heart I got the heart out of
there I think I see I got to stop the
bleeding oh yeah stop the bleeding got
our long nurse got air I can't operate
with damn lungs and my wife can you just
grab the needle ha ha grab it first try
jam it in there jab it keep jabbing
jabbing harder jabber good oh yeah that
was a good job that's a good Jeff those
great Radner shut up I know it is good
job just get the know get it out of
there
damn it my arm is not good enough I need
to replace it with a robot arm obviously
yeah get out I'm gonna I'm gonna stab
someone namely this guy right in the
eyeball Bob you can get away from being
stuck on a hole god
I just want to get to it I can't because
something blocking my bling blong a
wrist get the bones out of here I'm
going gree I'm so unbelievably angry I'm
sure right they think they can mess with
me
I got supreme medical training from the
director of Nicaragua Nicaragua
Nicaragua Nicaragua I am a Nicaraguan
nationalist code Z X 5 to 0 whatever the
hell this is I do not know or care what
this is but it needs to go get out get
out
nurse help come on
what the hell this is such bull look do
not see this just
oh my god okay y'all screw it it's good
good I'm going for it I'm going for the
heart give me that
bling blong you I've got two fingers
around oh oh this is flipping you off in
British land so take take take some of
that take so it is still a bunny foo-foo
all right whatever is that incessant
beeping again I just I just wanted it I
got it I got it I got it I got it I got
it
drop that in there I don't need that
anymore and do not lose his heart on the
way from here to there okay grab it grab
it got it and flip okie did a such a
fantastic job I know nurse I'm a doctor
doctor you really do know what's best
I know we did it we did it we did it
everybody we've successfully
I got a derating though well that's
because they're stupid
I want to I want to call Trisha wait a
minute there's a number here call Trisha
sharp I'm trying to call Trisha oh one
nine zero six zero two one two oh one
three shut up try to call someone here
oh shut up try to call Braddock okay
[ __ ] it whatever I'm just going for the
kidney transplant I don't have time for
any of this I'm a doctor hello hello
there friend what's your name I didn't
catch it
I'm gonna call you wall form until I
find out what's better you feeling good
hmm-hmm you feeling good good excellent
thank you very much okay now let's see
what the problem is yeah stupid cloth
you think they would fix this but they
did not
okay son of a [ __ ] you get out of my
operating room that's how I lost my
medical license anyway
and the doctor was never heard from
again some people say that I look like
say medic from Team Fortress 2 but
that's impossible it's not it's not who
I am
all right let's see and there's these
pills here that I haven't seen before
let's just um don't bomb in here Boop
oh wait this bottle is empty what the
hell where's all my drugs nurse what did
you do with my drugs
now I'm sorry doctor I thought you'd
like me better than nurse you don't know
it what's this what is it
[Music]
there I can't believe they trusted me
with a laser how do I get these organs
out I'm trying to blast away cache
sliced through the duodenum I need to
get to the ileum and get the large the
large colon out of there the colon in
the duodenum and he's bleeding pretty
bad I would think a laser would
cauterize the wound but this is not
working okay let's just forget that for
a second there and get the get the kids
get to Cappy just get to happy just get
the happy just oh I got the happy juice
I got the happy juice really uh hell
stop grabbing scalpels you dick jab jab
him jab him down and a bum Jabba Jabba
Jabba harder Jabba real good jab him
keep jabbing jab order harder
jab boom there we go there we go
ah yeah man whoa I feel better now
nurse have I ever told you your eyes are
like two orbs of white with a little bit
of color in the center how man
everything's so nice I feel relaxed and
at peace in man I never I never knew how
how pretty this blood was blood so
colorful and it's outside of the body
but still deliciously flavorful
oh look at the pretty colors ha ha look
at all the colors nurse yes how about
you and I how about you and I have a
special tie together right here here
here with all this colorful life and she
said Mr Sona look the way the colors for
[Applause]
[Applause]
well now is fun I'm glad you all enjoyed
it
did you enjoy you better have enjoyed it
for your next on the operating table got
a sniffle come to me I'll feel a scratch
come to me oh you bruised rib Oh God
take out your kidneys and replace it
with a brain two brains for the price of
one
anyway so I never that sad music that
was for the last episode this there's
this happy time so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos I've done and as always
[Music]
[Music]